unstoppable rivers of lava are edging
toward the sea following a volcano
eruption on the spanish island of la
palma
around 6 000 people have been forced to
flee their homes
experts are now warning of the dangers
ahead for residents including
earthquakes acid rain and clouds of
toxic gas generated when the molten lava
hits the water
an erupting volcano rumbles in the
spanish island of la palma from above
its molten lava moves quickly spewing
clouds of toxic gas and thick black
smoke into the air
homes roads and crops destroyed as far
as the eye can see
on the hillsides residents in shock
watch on as the lava and flames add
closer to more densely populated areas
thousands have been forced to pack up
and leave
over a hundred houses have been
completely destroyed
their residents now have nowhere to go
this is really frightening especially
for the farming and
la
fishing
depends on them a lot
local authorities are warning the lava
flows could threaten other areas
emergency crews are working around the
clock to help people retrieve their
belongings and evacuate quickly
the truth is that it's a tragedy to see
people losing their properties
you shouldn't take the earth for granted
spain's prime minister pedro sanchez
says he'll do what he can to help people
rebuild and keep them safe
your safety is guaranteed we've deployed
the state security and armed forces and
they're doing an extraordinary job for
the peace of mind and safety of everyone
this is the canary islands first
volcanic eruption on land in 50 years it
was triggered by several earthquakes
over the weekend as the molten lava
nears the sea
scientists fear it could create more
explosions and toxic gas the devastation
will cost millions and for many of the
residents forced to abandon their homes
it will take years to rebuild what was
lost
and let's get more on this we're joined
by david pyle he is a professor of earth
sciences at the university of oxford
thank you so much for your time
as we've been hearing authorities fear
explosions and clouds of toxic gases
once the lava reaches the ocean how big
are the risks
so the risks are local but they could be
severe and there's certainly a risk of a
risk of explosion when the lava comes
into contact with the sea scattering
blocks of lava ash and steam but that
will be localized to the place where the
lava enters the sea
a secondary hazard is that the boiling
of sea water by the hot lava can release
acid gases like hydrochloric acid this
has been seen in hawaii for example
and that lava haze is a very pungent and
accurate haze and so again it's it's
severe if you're
enveloped in it you don't have breathing
apparatus but the lava haze should be
blown away from the island and dispersed
by the winds
so the exclusion zone that's set out by
the authorities
should be sufficient to keep people safe
okay um so you know humans should should
therefore be safe i'm hearing from what
you're saying but how about marine life
so i think actually the impact of uh the
likely impact of marine life is again
relatively small um
that the the larva will enter the sea
and as it enters the sea it will freeze
and so most of the effect the physical
effect of the eruption will be in the
area where the sea
uh the lava and the sea combine at the
seashore
so in 1971 the eruption
the lava actually built out um a new
piece of coastline like a latch a
platform of lava and obviously in front
of that and underwater there'll be kind
of cascades of blocks of lava
um
running down the steep slopes into the
oceans
but actually the the again the physical
impact of that larp will be will be
restricted to the region where the lava
is coming into the sea
how about i mean because we've been
hearing um
that earthquakes on the island have been
continuing that there are new fissures
that have been opening up as well
how long do you see that this eruption
this situation going on
so this is the bit which is hardest to
predict and the only evidence we have
actually is the information from
previous eruptions
so the previous eruptions have lasted
from about three weeks the 1949 eruption
to about three months which was a couple
of eruptions in the 1600s so i think uh
your assessment right now would be
25 to 75 days
um but obviously that could change as
the activity continues and the
scientists have a much better idea of
what's going on in a couple of days time
or the next
time okay so so pretty big range there
volcanologist david pyle um really
appreciate your your expert analysis uh
filling us in on what what indeed is is
going going on there uh volcanologists
as we mentioned we appreciate it